[Musique]
combien de bouvier galvachers et autres
paysans morvandiau ont dû user de sabots
sur ces routes qui les mener vers
d'autres régions
l'âpreté l'aridité de leur pays les
contraignait à chercher du travail
ailleurs
quand on fera dans le nord loin vous
voulez vous il y avait une petite
culture avait pas vraiment de débit pas
beaucoup de viande alors il fallait
trouver un moyen de nourrir les hommes
alors rejoignez ravet des crapauds à la
farine de blé noir oubli et autres fera
pinelli très rapide fini c'est du rapide
bout des doigts alors la facilité de la
tourtière la femme du studio qui était
le plat de résistance des morvandiaux
arcand crise ont mené de la charrue
rappelé avoir fait un bon travail ou qui
au chili cacher les pommes de terre il
fallait tout de même lui retrouver
quelque chose à manger parce que dans
nos pays il n'y avait pas de bouche et
mon frère à l'épreuve et à autre chose
alors nous fait là tous tirent la
tourtière avec du fromage avec d'abord
des pommes de terre écrasées des pommes
de terre cuites à l'eau écrasé voilà
sans eau et sans lire à la du sel de la
farine
c'est plutôt son mobile iphone pattes
vous allez mettre sauf qu'on va médecin
ou dans la culture et les vous embêter
combien gens mais a tout de suite 1 2
dans la plus vite dans les pommes de
terre à la voilà je mets au fond d'la
tout tir en grèce avec de la grèce
s'était mis du beurre ni glisse ça
n'existait pas c'était de la glisse la
vraie grèce la bombe anglaise de cochon
et c'est pas trop gras nos hommes et
nous mais nos mains les paumes de
théâtre angie elle fromage aussi à ce
moment on n'était pas au régime de sa
vie voilà et le fromage maintenant on
ajoute un fromage un bon fromage de
firmes comme les morts vont elles savent
encore le faire c'était du fromage de
vache du fromage de vache on ne rit
maintenant les jeunes fermiers s'appuie
le faire le fromage et le beurre du lait
est là j'ai des fromages chez cipal que
des comprimés d'aspirine sait rien du
tout eh ben voilà tandis que les faire
livrer morvandelle les ensuite légué
elles savent encore faire notre fromage
alors on écrase un bon fromage de fer
avec de la crème 2e du sel un peu de
farine et aux mets ça sur ses pommes de
terre
[Musique]
maintenant mais on met ça maintenant
négrier et les grilles pour parfumer est
parfait le reste de la tourtière voilà
et combien de temps vous allez le monde
une demi heure une minute cela dépend
des iris oui j'ai été sur la brasure la
baise pas seulement j'avais quoi ça
commence à se manger tout seul ça se
mange en entrée c'était bourratif et
puis ma foi prêt ou salade voyez notre
fromage urines paul et voilà c'était le
repas dit mourinho
[Musique]